bien bon bonjour à tous donc je vous
propose de commencer la la deuxème table
ronde par un un constat qui est qui qui
est
terrible il y a un sondage qui est
réalisé chaque année pour le cvipof et
le CNRS par opinonway et qui mesure la
confiance que les Français ont dans
leurs institutions il faut regarder ce
sondage et malheureusement ce que l'on y
voit n'est pas rassurant puisque vous
avez 86 % 86 % des Français qui
considèrent que les responsables
politiques ne se préoccupent pas ou peu
de ce que pensent les gens comme eux 86
% des Français ont le sentiment que les
responsables politiques ne les écoutent
pas et puis vous avez un autre chiffre
67 % pensent que la démocratie ne
fonctionne pas très bien ou pas du tout
dans notre pays 67 % ils étaient 48 % en
2009 faut dire que ça c'est pas mal
dégradé depuis 4 ans on ne peut que le
constater mois après mois et et année
après année la démocratie française
est en panne un tel point d'ailleurs
vous avez vu qu'on est même plus capable
de faire fonctionner le Parlement
puisque alors que Nicolas Sarkozi
n'avait jamais recours au 493 François
Hollande sur la loyel
comerie pour la deuxème fois fait appel
au 493 bloquant le débat à l'Assemblée
d'ailleurs et provoquant aussi les
violences et les problèmes que l'on
rencontre dans dans le pays alors
comment réconcilier les Français avec la
vie publique avec les institutions et
avec la la démocratie il y a plusieurs
pistes que nous souhaitons explorer
inscrire dans le projet des des
républicains pour ma part j'en j'en voie
trois pour lancer les débats puis
ensuite je donnerai la la parole à nos à
nos invités euh première piste il nous
faut des institutions qui soient plus
lisibles et plus efficaces alors ça
suppose trois choses un peut-être que
l'on s'interroge sur l'intérêt ou
l'utilité de certaines de nos
institutions pense notamment au Conseil
économique et social et
environnemental moi je suis
parlementaire depuis 2007 pas une seule
fois à l'Assemblée nationale au sein de
la commission des affaires économiques
dont je suis le vice-président ou dans
l'hémicycle on a mentionné les rapports
du Conseil économique et social et
environnemental donc il travaille en
vasclos mais très franchement ça n'est
pas très utile en tous les cas pour le
fonctionnement de l'Assemblée nationale
et j'ai rarement vu des ministres citer
les rapports du Conseil économique et
social environnemental donc là une
institution qui coûte de l'argent où on
est entre soi et qui n'est franchement
pas aujourd'hui très utile donc soit on
la réforme en profondeur ou soit on la
supprime il faut qu'on se pose cette
question on sait par exemple qu'en
Allemagne les Allemands ont eu le
courage dans certains lenders je pense
notamment en bavia de supprimer purement
et simplement certaines institutions
dont il pensait qu'ell n'était pas utile
il faut qu'on ait ce courage en France
deuxième chose il faut clarifier les
compétences des collectivités
territoriales alors on se plaint du
millefeuille administratif français mais
là il est devenu carrément indigeste et
alors les socialistes ont réussi un tour
de force absolument incroyable puisque
ils avaient annoncé qu'il suppriment les
départements à la fin ils ont maintenu
les départements ils ont même renforcé
en créant ces grandes régions et l'air
de rien il y a un échelon supplémentaire
qui s'est créé depuis 4 ans qui sont les
pôles métropolitains les métropoles euh
alors maintenant on a les communes les
communautés de communes les commutés
d'agglomération les communautés urbaines
on a les pôles métropolitains les
départements les régions l'État et
l'Europe c'est absolument formidable ça
coûte énormément d'argent et c'est
terriblement inefficace puis il faut
aussi mettre fin à l'instabilité
législative et financière et françois
Barouin avec l'association des MRES de
France a proposé une grande loi des
libertés locales et un contrat de de de
mandature parce que on sait très bien
que les élus n'en peuvent plus de de de
l'instabilité législative des
allés-retours par exemple aussitôt élus
les socialistes ont rétabli la clause de
compétence générale des départements et
des régions pour pour 2 ans après
supprimer la clause de compétence
générale des départements et des régions
on a vécu depuis 4 ans des
allers-retours permanent les élus locaux
sont à bout n'en peuvent plus sans
parler évidemment des perspectives
financières puisque d'un côté l'État n'a
cessé de réduire les dotations des
collectivités et de l'autre de les
accabler de dépenses supplémentaires que
ce soit par exemple les fameux tap les
temps d'activités périscolaires qui
n'ont pas été financé et on pourrait
citer beaucoup d'autres exemples donc
nous nous souhaitons dans le cadre des 5
prochaines années une stabilité
législative et financière des
institutions plus lisibles et plus
efficaces des élus également moins
nombreux et plus proches de nos
concitoyens on a en France 1000
parlementaires 1000 parlementaires si on
ajoute les députés de l'Assemblée
nationale les sénateurs et les
parlementaires européens ça fait 1000
parlementaires c'est beaucoup plus que
la plupart des États comparables à à la
France et par conséquent nous proposons
de réduire d'un tiers le nombre de
parlementaires des parlementaires moins
nombreux et plus et plus efficace nous
voulons aussi revenir au conseiller
territorial rappelez-vous Nicolas
Sarkozi avait proposé que ce soit le
même élu à l'échelle d'un canton qui
représente à la fois les départements et
les régions c'était un bon moyen de
faire des économies et donner de la
cohérence entre leschelon départemental
et l'échelon régional nous souhaitons
revenir au conseillers territorial dans
le casre de canton aussi qui sont à
redessiner parce qu'il y a un véritable
charcutage dans mon département du du
Pas de Calais ils ont vraiment découpé
les cantons avec un seul objectif c'est
de garder le maximum de cantons et on a
des découpages qui sont complètement
incohérents et sur lesquels il faudra
évidemment revenir nous voulons
permettre aussi aux élus nationaux
d'avoir un mandat local parce que nous
pensons que il ne faut pas des députés
ou des sénateurs hors sol déconnecter
des réalités concrètes la loi sur le
cumul qui a été voté par les socialistes
est absurde d'ailleurs parce qu'on
peut-être député conseiller régional
dans des immenses régions mais par
contre on peut peut pas être député et
maire d'une commune de 200 habitants
c'est n'importe quoi nous nous voulons
des députés et des sénateurs de terrain
qui se confronte aux réalités concrètes
quand on estmer bien on a des problèmes
d'école on a des problèmes de de
personnes âgées on a des problèmes de
logement on a un budget à gérer on a du
personnel sous sa responsabilité c'est
important que les parlementaires aient
un ancrage local dans le cadre
évidemment d'une limitation normale du
du cumul des mandats à deux mandats mais
un mandat national et un mandat local ça
nous semble tout à fait
raisonnable et puis voilà et en la
matière il faut vraiment arrêtter la la
la démagogie enfin moi on le voit à
l'Assemblée nationale les députés Verts
ou socialistes qui à paratchi ont été
élu dans le dans la vague de 2012
derrière François Holland je peux
assurer que c'est une catastrophe il
raconte absolument n'importe quoi ils
sont complètement à côté de la plaque et
c'est malheureusement l'Assemblée et le
Sénat qu'on aura demain si on ne revient
pas sur cette loi absurde f la dernière
piste j'en termine par là sont des
citoyens plus écoutés et mieux associés
parce que on le voit moi je le vis en
tant que maire il y a une vraie volonté
aujourd'hui des citoyens d'être associé
au projet en amont de pouvoir peser
dialoguer être associé aux décisions
publiques et pour ça nous proposons un
usage plus systématique du référendum un
parlement réformé et puis nous voulons
aussi associer beaucoup plus nos
concitoyens aux
décisions qui les concernent notamment
par un meilleur usage du numérique alors
pour évoquer ces différentes questions
nous avons la chance ce matin d'avoir
avec nous Isabelle le calenc qui est
député d les vilen vice-présidente des
républicains en charge en parti du
projet concierre général d
Villen Virginie dub muler qui est député
de Haute Savoie et délégué général au
numérique des républicains d'applaudir
également et puis je veux remercier
aussi Fabrice Houn qui est entrepreneur
du numérique c'est comme ça qu'il se
défini qui veut mettre son expérience au
service des pouvoirs publics et qui nous
expliquera c'est ce qu'il m'a a dit en
préparant cette réunion que l'on n'a pas
pris la mesure de tout ce que l'on
pouvait faire s'agissant de l'usage du
numérique pour revivifier notre
démocratie et puis françois Barouin nous
rejoindra en fin de de matinée avant que
bien évidemment nous ayons la chance
d'écouter notre président le président
des républicains et je l'espère très
bientôt le président de la République
voilà merci c'est dit je donne
immédiatement la parole à Isabelle
lealec merci cher Dani bonjour à tous
donc tu m'as demandé ce matin de
raconter mon expérience d'élu local et
d'élu national parce que moi j'ai la
chance et et je le réaffirme c'est une
chance d'avoir un mandat local et un
mandat national tu l'as dit on l'observe
depuis 4 ans que je suis député les
députés qui ne sont que députés sont
parfaitement hors sol et votent des
dispositions dans les lois qu'il va
falloir digérer après sur le terrain et
s'ils avaient un minimum d'expérience de
terrain il ne nous proposerait pas ce
qu'il nous propose je voudrais revenir à
un instant sur ce qu'a dit Philippe
RAMBAL ça me paraît très
important par rapport à à l'action
publique et à l'efficacité de de
l'action publique qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire nous au Républicain donner le sens
et c'est tout le travail qui a été fait
sur les propositions depuis des mois et
le projet des
républicains s'attacher au management
qui va le faire quand on va être aux
affaires et on en reparle
tout à l'heure sur les collectivités
locales attention à ce qu'on ne duplique
pas les erreurs qu'on a commis au niveau
national dans nos collectivités locales
et sur le terrain et enfin
l'organisation c'est vrai qu'on en parle
pas toujours parce qu'on a le sentiment
que les institutions l'organisation ça
barbe nos concitoyens mais c'est
essentiel parce que sur les propositions
on va à peu près tous se retrouver parce
que il y a un principe de réalité quand
on est aux affaires mais ce qui va faire
la diff différence c'est comment on va
le faire avec quel état d'esprit et avec
qui on va le faire donc je pense que ce
qu'il a dit tout à l'heure s'applique à
la fois au niveau national et au niveau
local sur le niveau local j'ai envie de
dire même chose il faut qu'on se pose la
question aujourd'hui de ce qu'attendent
nos concitoyens responsabilité contrôle
évaluation ça vaut au niveau national ça
vaut au niveau de nos collectivités
locales et nous salons l'arrivée de
notre président de l'Association des
maires de France françois Barouin vous
avez le droit de
l'applaudir statut des fonctionnaires
accès à la fonction et management là
aussi il faut qu'on se pose la question
très concrètement sur le terrain vous
avez des élus locaux qui voudraient
pouvoir manager leur administration mais
qui n'en ont tout simplement pas les
moyens ou alors qui les ont mais si s
les utilisent ces moyens ça leur fait
prendre un risque ils peuvent être mis
au banc des accusés et donc je pense que
là aussi sur la fonction publique
territoriale il faut se poser la
question du recrutement de la formation
et du management parce qu'il y a des
lacune manifeste dans ce domaine-là
enfin recentrer l'État et plus de
liberté aux collectivités locales et
tout est dit à travers ça donc je pense
qu'au républicains il va falloir qu'on
soit très clair sur qui fait quoi
qu'est-ce que l'État doit faire quelles
sont les compétences de l'État quelles
sont les compétences qu'on transmet mais
il faudra les transmettre jusqu'au bout
aux collectivités locales ça ce sera une
vraie décentralisation et une
déconcentration qui ira avec euh avec
les institution de l'État et j'ai envie
de dire c'est vraiment le moment de se
poser la question puisqu'on se la pose
pour l'Europe on a réaffirm pas plus
tard que cette semaine à la faveur du
terrible brexit euh qu'il fallait qu'on
voit ce qu'on allait confier aux
institutions européennes et bien pour
savoir ce qu'on va confier aux
institutions européennes avec ce
principe de subsidiarité qui a été
rappelé il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
nous conserver à nous seul l'état
français ce qu'on va transférer à
l'Union européenne est-ce qu'on va
décentraliser déconcentrer au plus près
des territoires sur les collectivités
local là aussi attention à ne pas
reproduire les erreurs les
administrations dites indépendant
les agences les socialistes les ont
multiplié au niveau local ces derniers
temps et c'est-à-dire que avec ce
principe de la démocratie participative
qui a du bon bien évidemment les
citoyens maintenant ne font plus de
chque en blanc ils nous élisent mais ils
nous demandent des comptes régulièrement
mais là avec les socialistes ils se font
élire ils savent plus trop comment faire
une fois qu'ils sont élus parce que ils
a raconté un peu n'importe quoi il se
trouve que la gestion après c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué il dilapide
entre guillemets le pouvoir à leurs amis
parce que comme disait Eric vert c'est
pas du tout indépendant c'est en général
des agences ou des structures dans
lesquelles on recase ses amis et qui
sont autant de relais sur le terrain
pour aller porter la bonne parole faire
la promotion du prosélitisme et cetera
donc attention au niveau local et là je
le dis à tous ceux qui ont des
responsabilités ou qui veulent en
prendre au niveau local investissons
tous les champs et euh moi je suis
membre de la commission des affaires
sociales à l'Assemblée nationale
investissons le champ du social et de la
PGJ par exemple ne laissons pas ces
champs-là aux socialistes on a
énormément de choses à dire et quand on
est présent sur le terrain au milieu des
équipes les gens voient que nos valeurs
celles qu'on portent sur le terrain sont
autrement plus efficaces pour justement
lutter contre la pauvreté et faciliter
l'insertion donc attention à ne pas
reproduire cela on l'a vu avec les lois
tu le disais tout à l'heure euh donc ils
ont commencé les socialistes par changer
tous les modes d'élection pour essayer
de sauver tous leurs petits camarad au
départemental au régional ils se sont
euh bien bien bien bien trompés puisque
on a fini par regagner les
départementales avoir h régions sur 13
et ils ont tout modifié une espèce de de
de de mercato total de l'organisation
territoriale de la République la
première chose qu'ils ont fait en
arrivant c'est de supprimer la loi de
2010 qui instaurait le conseiller
territorial elle avait du très bon cette
loi moi je sais que j'en avais fait le
service aprèsvente dans mon conseil
départemental on réaffirmait le couple
commune communauté on réaffirmait le
couple département région on supprimait
euh les compétences générales au
département à la région on spécialisait
on était beaucoup plus clair et on
faisait plus efficace plus lisible et
moins coûteux pour les finances
publiques avec ce qu'ils ont fait la loi
maptam qui a réaffirmé les métop et qui
oublie qui oublie les zones rurales
ensuite avec la loi nôre qui a tenté de
redéfinir les compétences entre les uns
et les autres aujourd'hui on voit sur le
terrain concrètement moi je suis
conseillère départemental on doit
transférer un C nombre de compétences à
la métropole rennaise puisque je suis
élu en île et Villaines un certain
nombre de compétences à la région ce
sont des discussions sans fin et on voit
bien que les discussions qu'on avait
dans l'hémicycle sur ces questionsl on
les rrouve sur le terrain concrètement
et tout ce qu'on avait dénoncé pendant
les débats on le retrouve concrètement
dans les discussions qu'on a qui à mon
avis vont déboucher sur encore moins
lisible encore moins efficace et pas
forcément moins coûteux pour les
finances publiques on aura aussi à se
poser la question
oui ou non du redécoupage des cantons ou
des remodifications des limites des
régions alors on est face à une vraie
question on nous reproche de tricoté ce
qui a été tricoté par les autres on le
reproche d'ailleurs à ce gouvernement
mais d'un autre côté il faut aussi qu'on
fasse efficace donc je pense qu'il
faudra qu'on se pose en conscience
toutes ces questionsl aujourd'hui moi
j'entends les nouvelles régions elles se
sont données de nouveaux noms donc ça
veut dire qu'elles ont accepté cette
idée d'être ensemble mais quand vous
voyez certaines régions qui doivent
fonctionner sur des territoires immenses
avec justement ses agences ses élus ses
distances heureusement il y aura le
numérique merci à vous vous allez en
parler tout à l'heure mais en terme
d'organisation on a mis en place quelque
chose qui est absolument cfcayen et je
pense qu'on va perdre vraiment en
efficacité donc je pense qu'il faudra
avoir le courage de revenir là-dessus au
risque de se faire taxer de détricoter
ce qui a été fait avant mais là
franchement c'est n'importe quoi on
l'avait dit HERV Guimard l'avait dit je
me souviens de son expression c'est ni
fait ni à faire voilà sur le local sur
euh le le l'Assemblée nationale un mot
parce que ça me tient à cœur moi je suis
élu depuis 4 ans je ne supporte déjà
plus la façon dont fonctionne
l'Assemblée nationale je sais pas cétait
comme moi Virginie mais je trouve que
c'est inefficace on passe du temps à
blablater c'est
désespérant le dernier exemple en date
c'est celui que je vis actuellement sur
la loi dont tout le monde se fiche
égalité citoyenneté qui est une bombe à
retardement dans des tas de domaine
notamment du logement social ou de la
dite
citoyenneté moi je pense qu'il faudra
qu'on voit le mode de fonctionnement de
notre Assemblée nationale et je lance un
appel à mes collègues députés pour qu'on
travaille là-dessus moi j'avoue que une
seule lecture ça ça ira on a ans de
mandat donc ces lectures allerretour et
ses navettes personne n'y comprend plus
rien et l'opinion publique ne sait plus
où on en est et nous parfois on ne sait
plus où on en est la loi allure ça a été
un an la loi travail ça fait bon vous
savez je fais pas de détail et c'est pas
terminé un temps programme mais moi je
trouve que c'est intéressant aussi on
sait où on va et dans ces conditions-là
on se discipline et on travaille dans
dans dans dans nos groupes respectifs
les amendements qui sont pas retenus en
commission bah on les représente pas en
séance je veux dire on a eu le débat et
vous verriez qu'il aurait peut-être un
petit peu plus de présence dans
l'hémicycles ou dans les commissions si
on savait qu'il y avait pas une une
séance de
rattrapage sur et je crois que c'est
Guillaume qui l'a dit tout à l'heure moi
je crois qu'il faut voter des lois avec
les décrets qui vont avec voilà comme ça
on aura travaillé jusqu'au bout là on
est prêt euh on a préparé le projet on a
un certain nombre de lois cadre les
décrets qui vont avec puisque ça n'a
plus de sens et que souvent on
s'aperçoit que l'administration pour en
revenir à l'administration modifie
l'esprit ou tatillonne sur des points
qu'on avait imaginer à l'Assemblée
nationale et évidemment euh il il rentre
dedans on aura aussi si moi je pense à
modifier cette façon de faire on vote le
budget de l'État le budget des
collectivités regardez le nombre de
personnes qu'il y a dans l'hémicycl dans
ces cas-là puisque nous on examine en
commission aux affaires sociales le
budget de la Sécurité sociale pendant
que nos collègues examinent dans Séan le
budget de l'État on voudrait être là
pour examiner le budget de l'État on
peut pas on est en commission des
affaires sociales rajouter à ça et je
crois que c'est une proposition des
républicain le vote d'un budget pour les
collectivités locales pour qu'elles
sacheent où elles vont parce qu'il y
aura en effet un problème de de de de
finance donc là aussi si on veut
rajouter ce budget là il faut qu'on
puisse tous les députés je parle de ce
que je connais pouvoir accéder à ça et
puis je pense que si on fait ce travail
ensemble il faudra qu'on s'inspire de ce
qui se fait peut-être dans d'autres
parlements d'autres pays européens on
travaille pas assez on l'a vu à la
faveur là aussi des débats sur le brexit
on travaille pas assez avec nos
homologues Christian Jacob a réunir
récemment les le club des des 28 alors
on sera moins maintenant le club des 27
euh pour savoir comment et sur quel
sujet on pouvait travailler donc moi je
pense que on a on a un travail à faire
faire plus efficace plus lisible moins
coûteux pour les finances publiques
parce qu'on a pris un engagement de ne
plus augmenter les impôts voir de les
diminuer et mon dernier mot euh ce sera
pour dire que euh c'est vrai que pour la
la la la présidentielle il faudra
vraiment qu'on dise ce qu'on va faire
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
comment on va le faire c'est l'objet euh
de cette convention sur les institutions
qui était très importante euh pour
terminer cette série de de plus de 6
mois de de de convention et bien sûr
avec qui on va le faire mais ça avec les
républicains bien
évidemment merci
euh merci beaucoup euh Isabelle on ne
peut que que partager tes tes
propositions et tes constats qu'
s'agissent des collectivités
territoriales où l'État et et du
Parlement et en particulier de de
l'Assemblée nationale imaginez 577
députés qui n'ont plus aucun ancrage
local et qui passent leur temps à
déposer des amendements et à voter à
l'or àourdir les les lois qui existent
c'est une folie d'ailleurs Bartolone
nous avait dit vous savez on va voter le
cumule des mandats puis on va tout de
suite réformer le fonctionnement de
l'Assemblée ils ont voté leur loi
absurde mais par contre il y a aucune
réforme de l'Assemblée nationale qui au
contraire tourne à vide d'ailleurs le
débat qu'on a eu sur l'Europe hier
après-midi on a une bonne illustration
enfin voilà des heures de débat on va à
la tribune il y a pas de vote ensuite
voilà donc on perd notre temps en
blablatage il faut qu'il y ait moins de
déput des députés qui soient plus
impliqués avec un fonctionnement qui
soit complètement revu et là ce sera un
vrai électrochoc si on diminue d'un/ers
le nombre de parlementairire ce sera
l'électrochoc dont on a besoin parce que
nécessairement derrière il faudra
réformer en profondeur le fonctionnement
de l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat et
puisqu'il s'agit de redonner la parole
au peuple ce que nous proposons c'est un
référendum à l'occasion du deuxème tour
des élections législatives qui tranchera
toutes ces questions institutionnelles
sur les Français qui les trancheront de
façon à ce qu'on puisse ensuite les
mettre rapidement euh en en œuvre alors
ça c'est un aspect important du sujet il
y en a un autre que nous voulions
aborder ce matin c'est le numérique
parce que c'est une chance formidable de
pouvoir euh nouer une relation nouvelle
avec nos concitoyens et peut-être de de
combler ce fossé qui ne cesse de se
creuser comme je constatais avec vous en
introduction de cette table ronde et
pour nous en parler donc on a la chance
d'avoir ce matin Virginie qui est une
spécialiste de ces questions c'est notre
délégué général au Républicain du du
numérique donc on on va l'écouter avec
beaucoup d'attention on va écouter ses
propositions merci Virginie merci Daniel
effectivement le le numérique a apporté
un bouleversement profond dans notre
société c'est une thématique
transversale qui s'est instilée vraiment
dans dans tous les pans dans l'industrie
dans l'économie dans la santé dans
l'éducation et bien sûr dans
l'administration dans nos institutions
et également dans notre démocratie le
numérique est un outil formidable alors
vous le savez à l'automne prochain la
France va prendre la direction de l'Open
government partnership pour autant si
l'on parle d'un constat notamment de la
Commission européenne nous occupons
aujourd'hui la peu glorieuse 13e place
sur l'Union européenne en matière de
numérique donc on voit qu'effectivement
il y a beaucoup de choses à faire en la
matière alors on le sait l'État n'est
pas une start-up nos services publics
doivent pas être uberisés de la même
façon pour autant nous avons beaucoup à
faire et parallèlement à ce retard nous
constatons tous aujourd'hui un défiant
défiance envers nos institutions envers
les politiques en général notre
fonctionnement législatif et exécutif on
parle d'ailleurs de de crise du
politique de tout se pourri de scandale
médiatique de crise de confiance envers
les représentants du peuple et
finalement aujourd'hui on reproche à
l'administration ces structures
verticales des hiérarchies pesantes un
management basé sur la méfiance avec peu
de place pour la créativité la fracture
est donc imminente et il y a un enjeu
important d'agir rapidement pour adapter
notre gouvernance puisque aujourd'hui
nous sommes des citoyens du 21e siècle
avec des institutions qui datent du 20e
voire du 19e siècle notre démocratie
doit donc s'adapter à l'airre d'Internet
et nous devons trouver comment alors
bien sûr le numérique n'est pas la fin
du politique mais c'est une révolution
de la politique un formidable outil pour
la moderniser et permettre une
démocratie plus directe ouverte
simplifiée et contemporaine c'est une
chance également de révolutionner
l'engagement citoyen et d'améliorer
également la relation entre
administration et citoyens alors en
France vous le savez les initiatives ne
manquent pas il y a beaucoup de projets
qui existent déjà et en matière
notamment de Civic tech alors on a des
projets par exemple de coproduction
législative comme c'est permis notamment
le site Parlement et citoyen qui est une
plateforme qui propose en quelques clic
d'associer les citoyens à la rédaction
des propositions de loi sur lesquelles
nous travaillons c'est un vrai travail
de collaboration de coproduction un
texte législatif et qui est
effectivement intéressant je souhaite
également souligner la proposition de
loi de notre collègue Patrice Martin
laland pour Gén généraliser les
consultations publiques en ligne sur
internet pour l'examen de tous les
textes vous savez que c'est ce qui s'est
fait pour le texte République numérique
et également le texte que nous examinons
actuellement sur égalité et citoyenneté
mais il faudra réellement le
démocratiser parce que aujourd'hui si
vous regardez le profil des personnes
qui contribuent sur sur sur l'examen de
ces textes et bien finalement ce sont
des geeks qui connaissent parfaitement
la procédure législative parce que ça
demande quand même quelques compétences
et des personnes on va dire de CSP+ donc
il faudra effectivement donner les
moyens pour vraiment que la population
et tout citoyen puisse coproduire et
intervenir au moment de ces
consultations je pense aussi à à la
création d'un site qui s'appelle la vie
publique qui est une émission qui
propose sur sur Youtube de décrypter les
questions gouvernement avec la
possibilité d'interagir en direct via un
chat intégré il y a aussi des
applications de développement dans les
villes et métropoles comme c'est le cas
à Marseille Saint-Étienne ou anère qui
propose une application portable qui
permet à n'importe quel habitant de
signaler des problèmes de propreté de
manque d'entretien la mairie reçoit
directement la géolocalisation et peut
ensuite le transmettre à ses services
techniques donc ça c'est un vrai outil
qui permet une grande réactivité et qui
permet aussi d'instiller une culture de
résultats ce qui n'est pas forcément le
cas aujourd'hui dans nos collectivité je
m'intéresse également à la blockchain
puisque aujourd'hui cela permettra aux
personnes de réaliser entre elles des
opérations garantiese sans l'interaction
d'un tiers de confiance et on peut
penser par exemple sur les cartes grises
qu'on pourrait faire confiance à cette
technologie blockchain pour gagner du
temps et et enlever un intermédiaire
donc on le voit finalement ce numérique
est une forme formidable opportunité
pour nos concitoyens qui mobilise
l'innovation l'intelligence collective
la cocréation et qui permet de devenir
même des acteurs directs de leurs
institutions mais aujourd'hui l'action
publique en revanche évolue encore trop
lentement on manque notamment d'OP data
et mon collègue en parlera davantage
après moi au manque de numérisation des
procédures administratives par exemple
en mairie qui sont une perte de temps
considérable le récent rapport de mes
collègues Corine herel et Michel Piron
sur l'évaluation de la modernisation
numérique de l'État pointe d'ailleurs
des insuffisances en matière de
coordination des collectivités
territorial pour le déploiement des
services publics numériques les les
acteurs locaux reçoivent souvent des
injonctions venant de l'État sans
concertation sans valorisation des
expérimentations et initiatives locales
et donc les obstacles sont encore
nombreux à cette modernisation des
collectivités locales alors que les
bénéfices pour les usagers sont réels en
terme de gain de temps de
rationalisation et d'économie la
politique de la donnée doit d'ailleurs
générer une meilleure valorisation de
l'information qui peut-être propice au
décloisonnement des administrations à
son amélioration de fonctionnement et à
une optimisation des coûts mais cette
transformation implique une réforme de
taille c'est l'adaptation des agents et
des processus comme ils Appell l'a pu
l'évoquer précédemment et qui nécessite
bien sûr des investissement financiers
préalable donc on le voit effectivement
que la numérisation peut être une source
très très importante d'économie alors au
niveau des républicains nous travaillons
bien sûr depuis plusieurs mois sur ces
questions importantes et nous y voyons
un moyen important pour numériser nos
institutions et améliorer nos le
fonctionnement de démocratique et nous
avons donc formulé un certain nombre de
propositions concernant notamment la vie
des territoires il faut accélérer le
développement des smart cities donc les
villes intelligentes et notamment du Big
Data au sein des métropoles et
agglomérations pour pour développer une
collecte de données accessibles en temps
réel nous proposons aussi de créer des
centres d'opération numériques dans les
métropoles pour développer des modèles
pour la prévision et le contrôle par
exemple des catastrophes climatiques et
optimiser la gestion des services de la
collectivité transport police hôpitaux
gestion de l'eau électricité c'est aussi
bien sûr l'occasion de repenser
l'expansion des métropoles et créer des
espaces urbains attractif favoriser
l'émergence de bassins industriels et de
technologie de pointe c'est aussi
l'occasion de simplifier la relation
avec les administrations via deux
mesures fortes notamment à l'endroit des
entreprises d'abord la mise en place
d'un document unique numérique qui
regrouperait tous les formulaires
d'appel de cotisation sociale encré donc
sur une déclaration sociale nominative
et également une déclaration fiscale
unique et dématérialisée pour des
entreprises regroupant une liance
fiscale annuelle de la formation
continue la participation à la
construction les travailleurs handicap
AP la CVAE la CFE et cetera mais avec
cette modernisation de nos institutions
nous ne devons pas non plus tomber dans
l'angélisme la démocratie ne doit pas
devenir un marché de la donnée
personnelle sans protection ni sécurité
et naturellement la contrepartie c'est
de N ce que nous proposons en tout cas
c'est d'obliger des entreprises à
héberger en France les données qui sont
récoltées au sein de Data Centers cela
assurerait donc une meilleure
sécurisation des données des citoyens
une bonne application de la législation
française en matière de traitement de
données et développerit bien sûr des
emplois conséquents et derrière il y a
toutes les questions de souverineté
numérique auquel nous sommes
particulièrement vigilants enfin un
sujet sur la santé que Claude Greff
connaît bien aussi qui est effectivement
au cœur de nos préoccupations puisque le
numérique permettrait de développer une
filière de Laï santé permettrait aussi
de d'aider les professionnels de santé
et le développement des objets connectés
la télémédecine et la télésanté sont
aussi des moyens de favoriser le
maintien à domicile et de lutter contre
les déserts médicaux donc en conclusion
effectivement cette révolution numérique
est souhaitable et possible pour nos
institutions elle permettra plus de
transparence de facilité de coopération
et de solidarité c'est un nouveau modèle
à construire et bien sûr pour cela nous
avons besoin d'une seule chose d'une
vraie volonté politique je vous
remercie merci
beaucoup s clair et ce qui est
formidable c'est qu'on a tout compris
parce que parfois quand on aborde le
numérique il y a beaucoup de de termes
techniques qui se glissent de termes
aussi anglo-saxon et très vite on
décroche mais là c'était très très clair
et on comprend que il y a des
initiatives qui ont été prises il y en a
beaucoup qui sont encore à à prendre et
que dans ce domaine notre partie mais
également notre pays doivent être à la
pointe alors pour compléter ton propos
je donne la parole à fabriceoun donc
entrepreneur du du numérique expérience
importante dans ce domaine qu'il met et
qu'il veut encore plus mettre au service
des des pouvoirs publics monsieur Houn
merci beaucoup merci de me donner la
parole donc je voudrais remercier
effectivement Eric ver de m'avoir
proposé d'intervenir parce que depuis
des années maintenant je fais en sorte
de créer des liens des ponts du fait de
mon engagement personnel et patriote
entre le monde public et le monde de
l'entreprise et c'est encore plus criant
effectivement dans le domaine dans le
domaine du numérique donc je vous
remercie de ce ces propos qui vraiment
préparent l'intervention que je donne
derrière parce que finalement on va ça
va nous donner une vision un peu
multidimensionnelle vous avez la vision
du politique puis après vous avez la
vision de l'entrepreneur donc j'ai reçu
moi-même au bureau il y a une semaine
une délégation du Sénat pour informer
cette institution qui qui mène un
travail remarquable il y a il y a une
très grosse démagogie autour du Sénat on
a tendance effectivement à vilipander
les sénateurs mais il faut un travail
remarquable un travail de fond en
particulier sur ces sujets là donc on
les a reçu au bureau pour les informer
de l'importance de prendre il fallait
qu'il prennent conscience si vous voulez
de l'importance de du trait et de la
valorisation des données qui est un
enjeu non seulement un enjeu économique
important mais aussi un enjeu de
souveraineté nationale essentielle au
même titre que la sécurité alimentaire
ou que la sécurité sanitaire on a trop
peu tendance effectivement à en avoir
conscience en en France donc en en deux
mots j'ai été effectivement pendant
quelques
années directeur chez Cap géini avant de
décider de quitter pour diriger un
groupe indien que j'ai installé en
France et on est passé d'un effectif de
quelques salariés à 750 salariés en 2
ans donc il y a un vrai vecteur de
croissance économique pour euh dans dans
le domaine du numérique et j'ai décidé
de le quitter pour finalement prendre la
direction d'un petit groupe de service
plus de 200 personnes mais très
spécialisé dans ce qu'on appelle le Big
Data donc l'exploitation et la
valorisation des données pour les grands
groupes et malheureusement pas encore
pour les administrations puisque du fait
des codes des marchés publics on n pas
accès ou en tout cas très difficilement
accès et c'est un sujet que je vais
évoquer ensuite donc j'ai pris la
direction de cette société àin schéma et
nous sommes dans une logique
d'innovation permanente de fuite en
avant l'innovation
et la difficulté que l'on rencontre
effectivement c'est la perception que
l'on a en France du numérique c'est une
perception qui est très parcellaire qui
est très simpliste finalement on regarde
ça comme un nouveau média très souvent
et vous avez évoqué un certain nombre de
sujets madame le député vous avez parlé
de la blockchain qui l' très innovante
mais sinon vous avez parlé beaucoup de
finalement d'offre de service
relativement basique je vais déclarer
que ma rue n'est pas très bien nettoyé
donc il faut envoyer les services et
cetera or le numérique c'est bien autre
chose le numérique a provoqué une
révolution euh euh mondiale d'abord et
une révolution aussi au moins aussi
importante euh que celle de du 19e
siècle la révolution industrielle du 19e
siècle en particulier une révolution sur
les comportements et sur la perception
qu'ont les citoyens de de leur
citoyenneté et des institutions on est
dans un on finalement ça fait exploser
le modèle hiérarchique pyramidal euh que
l'on connaît et aussi bien au sein des
entreprises qu'au sein effectivement du
euh comment dire de la des pouvoirs
publics sauf que les entreprises en ont
pris conscience et peut-être pas encore
complètement les les pouvoirs public
donc il a maintenant les gens sont en
recherche finalement de lien de point à
point on est dans une société de
l'intermédiation on voit bien quand vous
prenez Airbnb et accord accord c'est des
millions de mètres carrés de de de
logement enfin de de de Real Estate et
vous avez d'un autre côté Airbnb c'est 0
m² d'immobilier la valorisation
boursière des deux sociétés est
équivalente pour vous donner une idée
effectivement d' quel point on est passé
dans une société de de l'intermédiation
uber de la même manière c'est zéro
véhicules en propre et pourtant
effectivement une société mondiale en en
très grand développement donc on a
finalement en France un rapport à
l'innovation qui est un rapport très
basique qu'est-ce qu'on appelle de
l'innovation en France aujourd'hui
blablacar bon enfin moi ça me fait pas
rêver je l'aventure entrepreneuriale est
absolument
extraordinaire sur le plan d'innovation
ça n'est ni plus ni moins que la
transposition de ce qui se fait
effectivement depuis des années voire
des décennies hein le le donc le
covoiturage sur le terrain d'Internet le
bon coin je sais qu' il y a eu un petit
débat sur le boncoin on a fait Gief au
président Sarkozy de ne pas connaître le
boncoin mais le boncoin c'est Paris Bou
boum c'est des petites annonces postées
donc il y a pas de quoi en faire quelque
chose extraordire donc on a déjà un
rapport à l'innovation en France qui est
un peu singulier est un peu simpliste et
qui ne n'est pas très propice
effectivement à favoriser cette
innovation donc finalement les pouvoirs
publics aujourd'hui ont un usage très
limité qui consiste à donner de
l'information à en récolter et puis
donc sur des usages effectivement très
basiques vous évoquiez donc un certain
nombre de sujets de de vous disiez que
par exemple seul les CSP plus plus venez
participer à ces sites voilà
participatif bon bah il y a d'autres
moyens grâce au numérique de rapprocher
les citoyens c'est par exemple la
captation des signaux faibles c'est
quelque chose qu'on connaît très peu
mais on a aujourd'hui toutes les
technologies qui permettent de mettre
des capteurs et de capter tout ce qui se
passe sur les réseaux sociaux tout ce
qui est effectivement déclaré c'est ce
qu'on appelle la donnée nonstuct urer et
de pouvoir consolider tout ça faire de
l'analyse pour pouvoir être pour pouvoir
soit anticiper des crises soit anticiper
effectivement des comportements c'est
utilisé par les banques par exemple pour
la détection de fraude mais ça peut être
utilisé pour tout un tas d'autres usages
donc voilà typiquement comment on
pourrait utiliser le numérique de façon
un peu différente non pas en
déclaratif mais en captation des des
signaux faibles alors finalement la
question c'est qu'attend les citoyens de
de des institutions et quelles sont les
cassures il y a il y a selon moi en tout
cas en tant que membre de la société
civile deux principales cassures la
première c'est l'inefficience
l'ineéfficience d'un certain nombre
d'institutions et la deuxième c'est
l'éloignement et la déconnexion entre
ces institutions et les citoyens alors
quand je parle d'inefficience je vais
prendre mon autre casquette celle de
conseiller prudomal ça fait 14 ans que
je siège au conseil des prudomes de
Paris et là je peux vous dire que on
narrête pas de parler de l'explosion des
délais de traitement des dossiers et
donc le le le le justifiable qui est
effectivement très malheureux de cette
situation là on est vraiment dans le
cœur du sujet Comment rapprocher les
institutions et le citoyen parce que là
ça touche les personnes au moment elles
sonit en général le plus vulnérable et
ben je vais vous donner un exemple de de
de donc de conseiller prudomal 14 on a
14 affaires inscrites ce qu'on appelle
inscrit au rôle à chaque fois que je
siège parfois il nous arrive d'en
écouter deux sur les 14 les autres sont
renvoyés est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
utiliser le numérique pour mettre en
état les dossiers plutôt que d'avoir des
avocats qui en séance viennent vous
expliquer que finalement bah ils sont
pas en état de pldder puis on leur donne
une date 6 mois plus tard et ils ont
encombrer le rôle pour rien voilà
typiquement le genre de chose qui
pourrait être très facilement mise en
œuvre je vois que on a notre magistrat
qui sourit voilà donc voilà le type de
de mesurees j'essaie d'égrainer au fur à
mesure des mesures pour ne pas être trop
ennuyeux qui pourraent être misise en
œuvre qui sont très faciles à mettre en
œuvre et qui permettrait de rapprocher
en tout cas de de changer la perception
qu'a le citoyen des institutions parce
que très souvent il y a pas seulement un
problème de il y a pas sou un problème
réel mais parfois il y a simplement un
problème de perception de l'action qui
est qui est menée et donc c'est bien de
faire aussi aussi ce travail pédagogique
mais de rendre plus efficient les les
institutions alors la problématique elle
est qu'on peut pas tout casser on sait
bien qu'en France c'est très difficile
de réformer et de tout casser donc
finalement on a aujourd'hui des pouvoirs
publics qui sont organisés en silo et ça
c'est un des problèmes majeurs pour
l'efficience je pense on vit aussi dans
les entreprises privées les grands
groupes sont organisés comme le pouvoir
politique vous savez des des des
chapelles des silos et et donc plutôt
que de casser pardon ces silos ce qui
est quand même extrêmement compliqué et
long l'idée c'est de créer grâce au
numérique des structures virtuelles
transverses la DA là donc la la
direction de l'information légale
administratif commence à le faire mais
commence seulement à le faire
effectivement de créer des structures
transverses qui permettent finalement de
passer outre ces silos et d'avancer
malgré les les les blocages que l'on
peut avoir à réformer les les les
structures de l'État alors voilà
typiquement le genre de de d'action
qu'on peut mener alors pour cela il faut
que les pouvoirs publics les
institutions s'ouvrent à l'innovation et
la difficulté je vais venir à mon propos
principal et une des solutions c'est que
finalement aujourd'hui on fonctionne
selon le mode
idée projet donc on a une idée puis on
fait on mène un projet pharaonique qui
aboutit des années après avoir été lancé
et il faut beaucoup plus passer
maintenant par
l'expérimentation je suis je suis
peut-être long non on dit que les
politiques sont bavardes ah oui mais
excuse-moi donc je vais finir là-dessus
il faut peut-être passer plus par
l'expérimentation effectivement c'estàd
qu'on lance un petit projet on vérifie
si ça marche on lance une touche et puis
si ça marche on déploie si ça fonctionne
pas on a perdu quelques dizaines de
milliers d'euros et je pense qu'il
faudrait effectivement passer par du
bottom up plutôt par par du topd c'est
une des des solutions excusez-moi alors
plutôt que d'avoir les sachants d'un
côté et puis effectivement les gens qui
subissent de peut-être de de faire un
peu plus de partir un peu plus de la
base et pour ça faut probablement
changer le code des marchés publics pour
donner accès aux petites entreprises
dynamique et innovante qui sont celles
qui peuvent porter cette innovation
merci merci
merci beaucoup pardon de vous avoir un
peu bousculé à la fin mais voilà c'est
important que chacun respecte ses ses
son temps de parole d'autant plus que si
c'est possible on aura un petit échange
avec la salle mais ce que vous avez dit
est passionnant moi je pense qu'il y a
aussi sans doute des pistes d'économie
puisquon veut on souhaite faire des
économies l'action publique
l'administration peut aussi être
beaucoup plus
efficace grâce aussi au au numérique
parce qu'on peut avoir une relation en
direct avec nos concitoyens sans
forcément mobiliser du personnel et des
locaux donc je pense qu'il a il y a là
aussi une piste à à creuser alors on a
la chance d'avoir françois Barouin avec
nous ce ce matin je vais immédiatement
lui donner la
parole on a on a évoqué depuis ce matin
la question de la clarification des
compétences parce qu'en fait le paysage
institutionnel est complètement brouillé
depuis depuis 4 ans on sait que les
collectivités ont eu beaucoup à souffrir
de cette instabilité législative du
manque de visibilité du point de vue
financier aussi avec des dotations qui
n'ont cessé de baisser des charges
financières qui accable les
collectivités territoriales donc on a
besoin de d'un CAP de vision de
stabilité de clarification sur la durée
du mandat donc sur tous ces points je
sais que tu as beaucoup travaillé
François et est-ce que tu quelles sont
tes tes propositions les provisions qui
pourrait être du coup également celle
des républicains mes propositions sont
celles des républicains évidemment on y
a tous travaillé je voudrais d'abord
remercier Daniel et puis saluer Eric
vert et toute l'équipe à la fois d'élu
d'experts qui ont mené un travail
fantastique depuis plusieurs semaine et
plusieurs mois et je veux leur rendre
hommage y compris sur cette dernière
convention à travers les institutions
concernant le cadre général collectivité
territoriale est à juste deux trois
idées simples à retenir le premier c'est
que lorsque l'on parle de dotation on
parle de l'argent que l'État doit aux
collectivités local l'état supprime à
supprimé par le passé des impôts locaux
la Constitution l'oblige à rembourser à
l'euro l'euro l'argent qu'il a retirer
l'état transfèt des compétences la
Constitution la loi fondamentale lui
crée des obligations de rembourser à
l'euro l'euro l'argent pour financer les
compétences nouvelles exercées par telle
ou telle collectivité territoriale donc
lorsque l'on a parlé de dotation lorsque
depuis 2 ans nous avons mené une
mobilisation avec tous les maires de
France quel que soit d'ailleurs les
sensibilités puisque l'immense majorité
des maires ont accompagner notre
revendication dans ce bras de fer avec
l'État nous avons porté un débat de
revendication légitime autour d'une
décision qui n'a pas été acceptée dans
la méthode et qui a été évidemment
contestée sur le fond très puissamment
qui est la réduction de 30 % des
dotations à l'espace de 3 ans de
l'argent que l'État doit aux
collectivités locales pour assumer de
nouvelles missions 30 % les conséquences
ont été immédiates et nous n'avons cessé
de prendre l'opinion publique à témoin
sur ce sujet et elles ont été de trois
ordres la première décision pour un
certain nombre d'élus pour les maires et
les intercommunalités élu en 2014 cette
décision a été d'augmenter la fiscalité
locale dans l'ordre de 30 % la deuxème
décision a été évidemment de réduire un
peu la voilure concernant les services
publics et les subventions au tissus
associatifs et la troisème décision
peut-être la plus importante a été de
réduire l'investissement public en 18
mois l'investissement public porté par
les collectivités locales est tombé de
25 %. 10 % d'investissement public dans
un modèle économique comme celui de la
France c'est 02 à 03 points de
croissance 30 % en moins
d'investissement public c'est 06 à 07
point de croissance la France est en
dessous de la moyenne des économies
membres de la zone euro vous avez là
l'une des clés réel de l'explication des
raisons pour lesquelles notre pays n'a
pas été à l'auteur de la création de
richesse et naturellement de la création
d'emploi sur ces deux items vous avez
une compréhension du rôle et de la place
aujourd'hui des collectivités locales
dans le dispositif économique de notre
pays l'économie de notre pays repose sur
deux piliers le premier c'est la
consommation le deuxième c'est
l'investissement l'investissement privé
il y en a malheureusement très peu
l'investissement étranger c'est
largement ralenti on a fui notre
territoire notamment depuis l'élection
de François Hollande qui a adressé des
messages absolument hallucinant donnant
l'impression que seu la Corée du Nord et
la France étaient les derniers pays
marxistes euh de de
notre situation internationale je
salue notre président Nicolas
Sarkozy et s'agissant de
l'investissement public l'État ne fait
plus que 5 milliards sur un volume
global de 50 les collectivités
territoriales portent 46 milliards de
cet effort nous portons donc 70 % du
potentiel de rebond économique donc ce
qui a été misise en place est évidemment
une très mauvaise manière a été en
réalité le sacrifice des collectivités
locales dans une négociation avec
Bruxelles pour reporter la date des 3 %
à 2017 et en quelque sorte l'État s'est
essuyé les pieds sur le dos des
collectivités locales sans dialogue sans
discussion sans méthode et avec un
objectif fou qui a abouti à une erreur
économique magistrale qui a été
défondrée et de retirer le tapis sous
les pieds des acteurs économiques que
sont les collectivités locales car la
restitution de l'argent du cont
distribuable par de la commande publique
tient nos territoire il ne faut pas
s'étonner de voir les perspectives
effrayantes de cet effet de ciseau
terrifiant de voir au moins 60000
emplois menacés de disparition dans le
bâtiment et les travaux publics à
l'horizon fin 2017 60000 emplois sur
250000 d'une industrie d'une économie
qui V de la commande publique et qui
tient la totalité des territoires il
faut donc remettre évidemment dans la
perspective naturelle ce qui semble être
le bon chemin remettre en cause cette
programmation des dotations les
arbitrages rendu par le président
Sarkozi à l'époque dans un contexte
beaucoup plus difficile puisque nous
étions au cœur d'une crise financière
qui n'a pas de précédent autre que celui
1929 nous avait amené c'est le l'ancien
ministre de budget qui s'exprime à faire
le gel des dotations c'est-à-dire que
nous n'avions pas fait l'impact de
l'inflation qui était à l'époque à 17 ça
rapportait 1 milliard et demi là
l'effort qui a été demandé en 3 ans
c'est 28 milliards on ne peut pas mettre
en comparaison ce que nous avons porté
qui était responsable raisonnable
équilibré avec une mesure qui est un
sacrifice incroyable et qui a des
conséquences considérables donc premier
élément remettre en cause le cadre de la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques deème élément de réflexion sur
ce plan institutionnel réfléchir à la
méthode en avons discuté avec le
président avec Éric avec tous les autres
on ne peut pas continuer à avoir Bercy
qui traite les collectivités les agents
économiques que nous sommes des gens
élus somm pas des fonctionnaires au
service de l'État nous exerçons des
missions de service public au nom de
l'État mais nous sommes pas des
fonctionnaires nous sommes des élus nous
incarnons des territoires nous
garantissons son unité pour chacun de
nos territoires et nous voulons un
dialogue qui soit autre que le ministre
du Budget présente la loi de finance en
conseil des ministres fin septembre et
ensuite ajuste comme il l'entend cette
ligne budgétaire des dotations c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous portons et je
m'en réjoui cette idée d'une loin de
financement des collectivités
territoriales c'est normal les dépenses
publiques représentent 57 % du volume
global rapporté à notre PIB il y a trois
sources de dépenses la première c'est la
sécurité sociale elle est de l'ordre de
640 milliards la deuxième sont les
dépenses de l'État de l'ordre de 280
milliards hors dettte et pension la plus
petite source de dépensees ce sont les
collectivités territoriales de l'ordre
de 230 milliards il y a une loi de
finance pour le budget général il y a
une loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale il doit y avoir une loi de
financement des collectivités
territoriales texte à l'intérieur duquel
la représentation nationale discutera au
vu et au-essus de l'opinion publique
texte texte à l'intérieur duquel tous
les ministres sous l'impulsion du
Président et du Premier ministre auront
l'obligation de fixer aussi le cadre des
normes qu'ils comptent prendre pour
qu'il y ait une discussion et que la
discussion ainsi transparente
n'alourdisse pas non seulement les
dépenses mais permettent d'avoir aussi
une perspective il nous faut aussi ce
que j'ai apprécié dans les travaux menés
parert et toute l'équipe euh un
caractère raisonnable personne aucun
maire en France ne contest ne conteste
la nécessité d'apporter une contribution
à l'assaainissement des finances public
mais il faut que ce soit de manière
modérée l'effort de l'ordre de 5
milliards qui est précisé pour toutes
les collec activité territoriale à
l'échelle de la prochaine législature
est un effort vraiment raisonnable
mesuré responsable dont on pourra
ensuite discuter de l'affectation selon
les collectivités territoriales entre
les régions les départements et les
communes et les intercommunalités mais
nous sommes dans un cadre général qui
est à peu près acceptable et évidemment
on fait le Paris d'une augmentation de
la croissance un dernier mot si vous le
permettez avant de laisser évidemment
les mots de conclusion au président
Sarkozi sur l'aspect institutionnel dem
155 aura été la pire année
institutionnelle que l'on aura jamais
imposé aux élus de France le texte sur
les grandes régions on a créé des états
plus grands que la Belgique plus grand
que le Danemark avec un mode de scrutin
qui confère une légitimité mais on a
donné une assiette fiscale tellement
étroite et des responsabilités tellement
immense qu'il n'est pas douteux que dans
très peu de temps les présidents de
région et c'est normal iront voir le
futur chef de l'État pour des
revendications de nature fédérale est-ce
que c'est ce chemin politique que nous
voulons ou est-ce qu' au contraire nous
voulons un état qualifié sur ces
missions essentielle régalienne et qui
puisse avoir une logique d'aménagement
du territoire corriger les handicaps
démographiques géographiques économiqu
et donc jouer son rôle non pas
d'accompagnant de la loi du plus fort
mais de rééquilibrage pour permettre à
chaque territoire de se développer de
manière harmonieuse deuxième texte la
loi sur les métropole Isabelle en a
parlé c'est très bien d'avoir 16
métropoles puissantes mais ça ne peut
pas ê des trous noir qui attirent toutes
les énergies et qui fait que la
l'immense majorité de nos territoires
seront en grande difficulté je rappelle
que 36000 communes sur les 36000 on a
33000 pour moins de 2500 habitants c'est
36 % de la population française ce sont
25 millions de Français qui vivent ce
sentiment global tout pour les régions
et tout pour les grandes métropoles
comme un sentiment d'abandon et il ne
faut pas s'étonner de voir dans la
partie rurale de notre territoire y
compris dans les values moyennes un
basculement dans un vote extrémiste tout
simplement qui est un cri d'alerte sur
le thème écoutez-nous aidez-nous
accompagnez-nous et nous voulons aussi
nous lever une génération qui demande un
nouvel espoir troisème texte la loi nôre
la menace a été terrible sur l'identité
communale nous avons sorti au Congrès
des MRES de France un sondage
exceptionnel sur un panel de 20000
personnes 75 % des Français marquent un
attachement viccéral à la commune la
commune c'est la dernière grande patrie
c'est la dernière grande famille on ne
peut pas être de nulle part c'est une
chance d'être quelque part ce quelque
part c'est la commune et c'est la France
c'est autour de cela que nous devons
réfléchir à un schéma institutionnel qui
permettra de préserver l'essentiel qui a
été menacé dans la loi nôre et qu'il
faudra naturellement corrigé c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans le document
institutionnel il y a me semble-t-il le
chemin d'intégration qui permettra de
restaurer un État fort sur son autorité
ses missions essentielles et des
collectivités territoriales qui joueront
des rôles d'amortisseur social de
solidarité et en même temps d'agents
économique au service du rebond de notre
pays bien je vrais remercier les
intervenants de de cette table ronde
François baren Barouin bien évidemment
monsieur Houn Virginie et Isabelle vous
avez compris dans le domaine des des
institutions comme dans tous les autres
nous avons vécu 4 ans de de cafouillage
de de revirement de déstabilisation
aussi d'un gouvernement qui n'avait
aucun cap de cauchemar nous dit Claude
Greff mais c'est vrai que par moment en
tous les cas en tant qu'élut local c'est
comme ça que nous l'avons vécu nous
avons besoin pour les 5 années qui
viennent de de vision d'un d'un CAP de
stabilité d'une feuille de route de
courage également et c'est sont ces
valeurs et ces principes qui sont au
cœur du projet des des républicains qui
sur le plan des institutions va nous
être présenté dans quelques instant par
notre notre président parce qu'il nous
faudra pas qu'un projet il nous faudra
aussi un homme qui soit capable
d'incarner et de porter ce ce projet et
comme beaucoup d'entre vous cet homme je
le souhaite en tous les cas ce sera
Nicolas Sarkozi merci